hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book six of his lives of the
philosophers diogenese Laertes is going
to provide us with a sketch of the
doctrines I had doxography that is a
statement of what it is that they
actually believed and taught and lived
by of the sirenic hedonist school which
was started by aristipus and he's the
main sort of Representative of it early
on the originator of it so looking at
his life can also be quite useful for
certain incidents and that's actually
where we should begin before launching
into all of these other discussions of
Pleasure and Pain so aristipus is being
criticized for enjoying the favors of
lice who is a very famous hatera or
prostitute a companion literally and so
to those who were criticizing him his
defense was I have lice not her me and
this shows you a really important
attitude he tells us that what is
actually best is not abstinence from or
literally not using uh tomes thy
Pleasures but rather the Mastery uh
tokraten of pleasures and not being
mastered or worsted beaten by them so
it's fine to pursue pleasures and as
we're going to see it's fine to pursue
all sorts of Pleasures regardless of the
source what's most important is that you
can actually say no when you want to as
a matter of fact talking about another
incidents where somebody is criticizing
him for going into the house of a
prostitute he's says the problem is not
going in the problem is not being able
to go out when you need to
so what is it that they actually thought
about Pleasures well here we get to
another really key Doctrine and there's
a important qualifier here they think
that pleasure is the end and the good
right so this is what makes them
hedonists that is the essence of a
hedonist Doctrine along with that would
be the opposite pain is the bad uh pain
is the thing we want to avoid the most
but notice that there's this important
other bit to it right what is it well
particular Pleasures not just pleasure
per se but actual Pleasures that we
enjoy so he calls these in some cases
right a pleasure that is a part or a
pleasure that is Kata uh right so
not happiness as an aggregate or some
sort of overall State eudaimonia but
rather enjoying pleasure right here
right now in the present and of a
certain sort so it is the end the Telos
the thing that we you know choose that
we ought to be for smart uh wanting and
he tells us that
um pleasure particular pleasure is in
fact desirable for its own sake the
Greek for that is the Howton
something that we choose we we put our
hands on
for itself through itself we want
pleasure and it's good agathon and you
know he provides some evidence for this
right he says that pleasure is the end
is proved by the fact that from our
youth up we are instinctively
attracted to it right and when we obtain
it we seek for nothing more and we shun
nothing so much as its opposite pain so
you know these are some important you
could say arguments that are being
provided once you have pleasure you're
doing good right you feel good you don't
need anything more that's a sign that
you've reached the end the the goal
we shun pain we try to avoid it in
whatever ways we can and a little bit
later he says well what about people who
don't choose pleasure right they
deliberately abstain from it or
something and so his his school says
that some people may fail to choose
pleasure right uh on occasion why
because their minds are screwed up their
minds have been literally turned in the
wrong direction and you know this could
be a lot of different reasons it could
be that they're afraid of social
disapproval it could be bad habits it
could be that there's something actually
wrong with their physical condition it
could be that they feel guilty about the
pleasures that they engage in now the
analysis of Pleasure and Pain in this
says that from the aristipian point of
view there are two basic States and both
of these he calls Kinesis meaning motion
or change there there's something
actually happening so one of these is
pleasure Hayden a smooth motion lay on
kinesian the other and he uses several
different terms for pain interestingly
in diogenes Laertes reporting it's not
the term that we would expect to see the
most Lupe which we typically translate
directly as pain but can also mean you
know trouble or other sorts of mental
anguish and things like that he actually
uses the word ponan which means
something like toil or something that we
just don't want to do you know chores
our example so that but he also uses uh
all again you know Composites of that
which does also mean pain when we talk
about an analgesic and we take a pill to
stop our headache or our physical pain
mean that's coming from that Greek term
so he's using several different uh
terminal
particular connected terms for that and
he says that it's a rough motion
right so this is what distinguishes on a
physical level Pleasure and Pain not all
pleasures and pains as he points out are
necessarily bodily or somatic or
physical some can be mental or of the
Soul tsuki K and it gives us an example
of that the pleasure of you know taking
joy in one's own country one's Homeland
but for the most part he's going to be
focusing mainly on physical and and or
bodily pleasures and pains
um so
why uh focus on the bodily pleasures and
pains this school held contrary to the
school of epicurus another hedonist
school that became more popular that's
uh coming a little bit later on in
ancient history that
physical or bodily pleasures and pains
are better and worse than mental
pleasures and pains and some of this is
you could say phenomenological they're
saying this is just how it actually
appears to us this is our experience but
some of it is also a matter of reasoning
right so they will say that you know
offenders are punished with physical
pain right we should pay more attention
to the body and to the to than to the
mind and most importantly and this is
again where they're going to differ from
the epicureans so the epicureans
held that actually mental pleasures and
pains are are more important and one
reason is because you can use your your
projection ahead into the future your
expectation of hoping right or your
memory of past Pleasures to produce
present pleasure for yourself and so the
aristipians or crnaics a yeah that's not
the case I mean you can have a memory of
enjoying a good thing but that sure as
hell is not the same as the pleasure of
eating that steak or candy bar or
indulging in that you know sexual
activity or whatever it happens to be
right now in the present the present is
where we actually encounter pleasure and
once that pleasure is gone it's gone
right you're not bringing it back and
dwelling on it and enjoying the same
sort of pleasure they also deny going
back to this two states that there's any
sort of real intermediary State they say
well you know in between Pleasure and
Pain is kind of like a
you know a neutral a Gap a neither uh
pleasure uh I Adonia and neither pain
opponia right
um so there's the ah is a primitive it's
just saying the lack of and the
epicureans thought that with the removal
of pain and trouble came the best kind
of pleasure a pleasure and rest and the
aristipians are saying yeah not the case
at all right it's not by the way just
the the epicureans who thought that
there were other philosophical schools
uh that we have you know some sort of
testimony about that that held a similar
position about the best thing is
actually not being pained not being
troubled just being able to chill out
and the aristipians nope that's not the
case right so we pursue bodily pleasures
and pains and they go even further they
say you know so it's fine to enjoy
Pleasures even if they are considered to
be shameful what we sometimes call
guilty pleasures right the pleasures
that we don't want to get out there in
social media that we are actually
enjoying because people might look down
upon us and the serenax and aristepus
say it doesn't matter where it comes
from pleasure is pleasure it's the good
so if you enjoy going to prostitutes
well that's just A-Okay for you you know
we've seen that in the discussions
earlier that aristipus himself could you
know bring prostitutes up to his door
and then say see you later no need for
you right now but that he also would you
know sometimes go and frequent them in
part because he's viewed that as a more
direct way to get the pleasure that he
was looking for there's actually a great
uh argument that that he provides as a
response to somebody who's accusing him
of living with a high Taira a courtesan
prostitute and he says is there any
difference between taking a house in
which many people have lived before and
taking one in which nobody has ever
lived and they said no and then he said
or sailing in a ship in which ten
thousand persons have sailed before and
in one which nobody has ever sailed and
they say there is no difference then he
says well it makes no difference whether
the woman you live with has lived with
many or nobody who cares all that
matters is
are you getting pleasure out of it and
so you know there there could be all
sorts of shameful things things that we
feel a sense of embarrassment about we
don't have to actually feel embarrassed
about it according to the Syrian ax it's
pleasure right and perhaps we could say
a similar thing with pain there might be
some pains that it would be shameful to
avoid who cares the good thing is to
avoid the the pain
um there are also Pleasures that require
pains or a lot of work or however you
want to put it for the their own
production right he says that the things
that are productive of certain Pleasures
are often of a painful nature right
the very opposite of pleasure and so
does this mean that we should avoid them
completely no we should you know we
should think about how we can prudently
run our lives it's as a translated here
it's a great translation uh it's an irk
some business right Deuce Co last Teton
right it's very
uh it's a real pain in the rear
figuratively speaking to go and get
these Pleasures that require so much of
us and you know in the very beginning of
the life of aristipus we hear that he
derived pleasure from what was PL
present right what was at hand paronto
and he did not toil he didn't put in
work
uh to procure the enjoyment of something
not present there's enough things to
enjoy in the present we don't have to do
an awful lot of work to get pleasure so
that's the typical cyranic uh view on
that the last thing that we have to talk
about is other things that people
typically value Prudence practical
wisdom virtue right moral goodness
Excellence friendship wealth these are
all considered to be good from a
syrianic perspective but they're good
insofar as they can do to pleasure right
so why is is it good to be prudent so
that you can run your life and enjoy as
many pleasures and avoid as many pains
as possible why is it good to be
virtuous well it keeps you out of
trouble right it allows you to have that
self-mastery why are friendships
important well because they can provide
us with the opportunity for pleasure
warding off pain wealth can help us in
similar respects but what really matters
is pleasure and the avoidance or the
reduction of pain this is the serenaic
viewpoint on this as articulated by its
founder and uh the you know teacher of
all of these these students who come
afterwards some of whom are going to
make some interesting modifications
aristipus the follower of Socrates who
is articulating one of the earliest at
least in Greek philosophy hedonistic
perspectives